so what's actually happened is the lion
actually stays in the wanky National
Park these the professional hunters
scented the area by dragging a dead
animal to an area but off okay from from
the park and lured the lion to this spot
and then they came in at night while the
lion was feeding with the spot locked
and shuttered with a bow and arrow they
didn't kill him straight away instantly
but anyway they took 40 hours to do a
follow up and eventually the caught up
with him and they killed her shot him
with her with a rifle a cruel death for
such a beautiful animal but it's given
that the the killing of Cecil took place
outside of the national park I mean is
it possible for criminal charges to be
brought well it is because there was no
quota for that area and no permit was
issued for this lion to be killed even
if the hunter had a license to hunt a
lion but it was in the wrong place wrong
time in the wrong area we're told that
the individual that moves said to be
responsible for the killing of Cecil I
paid some thirty two thousand pounds I
mean it sounds like it's big business to
actually be have the opportunity to take
on big game oh well it is but it's the
way it's done deny ethics is not there
the code of conduct be the rule of the
game is not being played at her - I mean
this line was being researched studied
by the research team in wanky which is
funded by the Oxford University and din
are we going back to square one and just
briefly if you could mr. Rodriguez this
the killing of Cecil is not just the
killing of one line that there are
obvious implications for the rest of the
pride well there is the the thing is he
left are quite a few Cubs behind and now
what happens is the as nature as it
happens in nature is that the next male
will come along will kill all the Cubs
so that he can bring the
females back into heat and actually
produced his own blood bloodline and
this is where the tragedy comes in